okay good day
everyone
we already have three wonderful sessions
on different topics
related to visual learning recognition
and reasoning
thanks for watching invitation
on regard to
organizing this panel
we can gather in here to discuss related
topics in deep
we have four leading experts
in this area
for this panel
they are professor
kim lee from soil national university
professor ima from uc berkeley
dr katjui kuchi from microsoft research
grammar and doug chung law
from microsoft research asia i'm
shilling chen
and
i'm from institute of computing
technology chinese academy
of sciences
i'm the moderator
here's the agenda
as mentioned in peers talk
deep learning
plus huge date training data
becomes a popular very popular paradigm
in computer region nowadays
after decades probing of diplomatic
it's time to revisit
the stress and weakness
of deep learning in computer region
in this panel
we expected that panelists will give us
some suggestions
or recommendations
on computer region
in next decades
both for academia
and industry
we also would like to receive
addresses
to next generation
from this leading experts
after panelists sharing
their valuable views on future of
computer vision
we will have some debates
on related topics
as all these discussions
are very often
the panelists are expected to have a
very short
summarize
to the audience
yeah here's our four panelists
i will yeah briefly
you just
introduce them then
they are invited to give us their
position
wheels and also about themselves
yeah the four panelists are professor
kim lee
from soil national
university professor
e ma
from uc berkeley
dr katju kuchi from microsoft research
grammar
and doc chung law from microsoft
research grammar
asia not really sorry yeah
i would like to
invite them to share their position
points within
three to five minutes per panel list
let's start from professor kimo lee
kimo
please
okay thanks uh celine for the
wonderful introduction i'm very happy to
participate in this you know a wonderful
uh you know
panel um the discussion with uh
you know many good friends here
actually let me briefly introduce myself
um
uh i'm kimberly from salvation
university
i've been with the soul national
since 2003 and actually i've been
working on computer vision
almost 30 years
now
i'm serving as a director of the
interdisciplinary uh program in
artificial intelligence in the uh
graduate school of the assault national
university uh launched last year
which is the representative
a.i program in
snu
where
now we have 53 faculty members
who covers
broad range of
you know ai
from core technologies to the many
different obligation areas
so i have served the
the
general co-chair of the iccb 2019 and
also served as the
uh associate editor-in-chief of the uh
it
came
until 2019
and will
serve as the editor in chief of ipt
permi from uh next year
uh
the research
topics i've been uh mainly interested in
are
visual tracking
object recognition
low-level image and video restoration
and recently
we are putting more effort on the human
cause and shape destination and also
some fundamental you know
machine learning uh algorithms uh
especially for the application to
completion problem like the meta
learning
and official learning continuum learning
and on supervised learning
so um
so regarding uh the
view on the future of division actually
we see that for the last decade
we
observed that
is unexpected and unprecedented changes
has been made in combivision by the deep
learning breakthroughs
some specific problems
that are considered hard to solve before
like object detection and classification
is almost solved exceeding human
performance as you all
uh as you are all aware
right
i think that this trend will continue or
be accelerated even accelerated
at least for the next decade
despite of these great advances
so far
however we are still far from
the general human level vision system
for fully understanding
uh the scenes
and many
challenges great challenges study made
for making real impact
by developing robust and adaptive vision
algorithms and systems
that can handle extreme cases
and
really working you know making really
working system in the
in the in the wild scenarios
will be one of the most important issues
uh so in the road map
to the artificial general intelligence
or artificial super intelligence
i think
the computer vision
will still play a crucial and
significant role
so
we have a lot of you know uh chances
to make it
you know great
difference in the future
okay so that's all
thank you
yeah
uh sex chemo yeah very clear points and
yeah i think it's very helpful
he makes a lot of efforts uh whiten the
black box of deep learning
this is quite
yeah confusing for a lot of researchers
so i think his work is very important
and
he just
shared some progress
on these topics
yeah he will give us incredible points
he please
uh thank you shooting for introducing me
and also
thanks for watching organizing this
panel and also also invite me for giving
a
kilo for at this summit um as the
shooting wasn't alluded to um i'm ima uh
i'm a professor at the university of
california berkeley my research interest
has always been computer vision as well
as the mathematical
principles or
computational principles behind how to
extract information from high
dimensional data such as images
and as she mentioned that
also kimu in his
presentation mentioned that deep
learning has tremendously changed
advanced the practice of computer vision
but uh for
but for a while the the deep network has
always been used as a black box right uh
despite the empirical success the
understanding of what really the deep
learning is doing as well as what the
role of the networks has always been a
challenging so some of my recent work
has really tried to
open that black box uh up
and
provide a purely white box approach to
derive deep networks from
the
fundamental principles
of information processing or data
compression so i give a talk about that
at this summit
and all right more related to this uh
panel right
and my work in the how do we provide
such a you know
lookout for the future of computer
vision so the area the specific area i
worked on computer vision is more
related to 3d vision
and we all see that
the
the classical 3d vision
has always been trying to recover 3d
model from a sequence of images right
by establishing correspondence and
recover the camera position and also the
a sort of the the 3d location of the
feature points and this is sort of the
base the basis for the the classical 3d
reconstruction pipeline we have seen a
lot of practical uh success including
the
slams and so on simultaneous
localization mapping relies on this kind
of technology
of course this also has two uh this kind
of classic approach has troubles right
and we know that uh when the thing has
deep lack of texture different type of
reflection or repetitive patterns large
baseline right has always presenting
challenges to this kind of classical
approaches which also suggests
to resolve 3d reconstruction we also
cannot just exclusively relies on
geometry we have to rely on applica
recognition
so hence uh in the past 10 years right
deep learning also has really
tremendously improved the capability of
computer vision in tasks such as
recognition
however
on 3d reconstruction
deep learning has met some challenges
right despite the tremendous progress
we're able to infer 3d pose
voxel point clouds or or geometry or
depth or even surface
and a more serious evaluation of these
methods actually suggests that uh the
deep networks at least
in the cat for the task of three
division is actually not that
necessarily better than very preliminary
methods such as nearest labor
so now the question is how can we
combine
the classic geometry based techniques
with the high level recognition data
driven recognition that boosted by deep
learning technology i think that would
be the challenge for the future of 3d
vision right so really that i'll be able
to combine the principles of geometry as
well as the
data-driven learning technology right
enhance the
ability in recognition
so there has been some recent work we're
trying to combine this classical
geometry with the learning based method
right
truly that
be able to use
recognition techniques learning-based
techniques to
learn and detect and correspond
high-level features lines planes and
vanishing points symmetry and so on so
forth i think this sort of marked a sort
of a good paradigm to combining geometry
with learning based method and this is
what i think would you know uh provide a
very
many exciting problems for future of
computer region
yeah thanks yeah thanks yeah ima for his
yeah wonderful i think points
and uh yeah
as ima yeah even he didn't mention that
yeah he
okay ima didn't mention that he spoke
yeah very
many many years ago yeah he write a book
on 3d vision
and
the 3d
has a very beautiful
mathematics like geometry and others
and nowadays death children should be
combining
with this beautiful mathematics
sex
okay
you cut katju
keeps working in this area for more than
40 years
for 40 years yeah
and his experience
and the prospects
definitely will be very helpful to the
young generation
because he starts from at that age shift
from shading
octoflow and where there are traditional
and typical topics in this area
let's invite the katsu to share his
wisdom
catch you please
okay
so basically long long time ago i got a
phd at you tokyo and then work at mit
etl cmu and utokio and then are
microsoft
and then you know
i have worked in three areas computer
vision robotics and its
and in a
computer vision area basically i mainly
work in physics-based vision and then
robotics are so called learning from
observations and also all together i
work combine everything into the
inheritance to preserve cultural
heritage by using computer vision
technique and robotics techniques so
that's my introduction
and now
i have coupled the
future view but in order to know the
future
we need the past
so-called
japanese and chinese and whatever
first of all from where we come from
and in my opinion or you know everyone
knows that you know uh a.i begin at the
dartmouth conference
three or four or five uh great people
including mcathy and minsky and other
people
and at that time computer vision
robotics are synonymous with ai around
that time
in fact you know
around that time
artificial intelligence laboratory mit
one of the
center of ai research at that time
complete is the following demo
one is a mit ai copy them
sensing the block world and then
understand the structure of the block
world and then create a structure by at
that time
three
phd students now they are great computer
vision progress at mit and
stanford and then some of them passed
away actually
and then uh 10 years later i and bkp
hong developed a bing picking demo now
again
pkp honda minsky
think that is one of the
direction which we should go
and at that time
we sense so-called donuts by using
photometric stereo and the time suffix
orientations
and then based on this surface
orientation
we determine uh object attitude by using
gaussian excel gaussian image and glass
plan
so important point is previous system
and current system
previous system and current system that
consists three components sensing
cognition and action
and the purpose of the artificial
intelligence laboratory was to create
artificial life form which consists of
these three components
however
marvin minsky and other people realize
each of the three components poses
challenges
and then a reductionism caused
let's divide and conquer
since enhancing computer developer
computer vision in
from each guy iccb was separated
and then
from each guy robotics components called
igla was separated and since then
computer vision and artificial
intelligence and robotics research in
parallel manner
and then
half
century later
cambodian explosion occurs in robotics
as well as computer vision
and of course the reason why
explosive cambrian explosion occur is in
biology
acquisition of vision was a main reason
why cambodian explosion occurs
then why
computer vision
a country explosion occurs
well computer vision acquisition of deep
learning and cloud technique is a
main reason why such cambodian explosion
cambrian explosion is good idea to
make many different techniques
however the result of cambrian explosion
is
extinction
too many species so most species were
extinct
only those optimized environment can
survive such
vast
extinction
so it means computer vision there is a
possibility such extension extinction
caused
then what we should do
we need a paradigm shift
previously we are mainly talking about
reductionism to make
discipline
fragmented and divide and conquer
but this is too fragmented and due to
that
in one sense explosion will cause
now we have to come back the origin
to move to tourism
and that tourism system to adapt the
environment so that we can survive our
community survive
we need a paradigm shift from
reductionism to horizon
and important point is in this tourism
we have to worry about environment
previous ai system
artificial life form we didn't consider
environment
then what is the environment
well
first of all why we are making
artificial life form
our artificial life form should work for
human in the human environment so
for the computer vision artificial
intelligence and robotics
artificial life form should worry about
environment human societies so we have
to make the
artificial life form for human societies
and currently we can think about two
types of artificial life form
one is terminator type
enemy type to complete human and
complete autonomous system
another one
in japanese cartoon there is a cartoon
called drama
this is a friend of human and cooperate
and help human
and augment human physical and
intellectual abilities
we should aim this diamond type
augmented artificial life form
one more thing
do
does any of the module current
deep learning want to learn
i don't think so
does any module have self-consciousness
if the goal to build the artificial life
form we should aim to design artificial
life form with
self-consciousness to help human
and in fact you know by thinking about
this one
recently we are working
artificial life form to serve seniors
most of the seniors in assisted living
facility would have preferred to remain
at home
but
if we can make a robot which learn
what to do from demonstration then
caregiver can teach official life form
at home
and then such as shell lifeform can help
seniors to enjoy their living at home
and empower them to be able to achieve
more
so in my opinion of course this is just
one example but we should worry about
this kind of artificial lipo
thank you very much
thank you
yeah
can you
yeah it's very yeah
i think it's very important
points
for
future
researchers
yeah because vision is just a part of
function of artificial
intelligence
and even for the whole ai should be also
working with the body
so
involvement
ai
whereas even
computer region should be the future
in the yeah maybe next 10 10 years
okay
next yeah let's move to
our last
the panelist
dr law
hello
hello this is
microsoft research asia i'm currently a
principal researcher with the
intelligent multimedia group
i'm also a
an adjunct professor
and phd advisor
in the university of science and
technology of china and in xi'an johnson
university
yeah
in the past i
actually
i'm not in the computer vision field for
um for all of my research career
actually i start my research career from
computer vision but then in the middle i
worked on um
video communication joint source coding
of video and
then coming back to computer vision a
few years ago
so currently
i work on
image and video understanding including
image classification object detection
and visual tracking
and
also
one of my main interests recently is to
do
disentangled visual representation
learning
and i also
work on multimedia editing including
both audio and video
processing and generation
so
in talking about the future of computer
vision
so i i think um the computer vision uh
research just as other uh the research
in other domains and can have blue sky
research or mission focused research
so i think both type of research are
important because blue sky research
helped us to
push the frontier
of
of the research and of the uh human uh
ability
and um
mission focused research is the really
um practical research that is uh useful
right
so
i think in in sky research
i'm quite interested in representation
learning and um
especially the disentangled
representation learning learning and
also the cross-modality
learning so
vision actually is one of the human
senses so i believe computer vision
should only be one of the
computer senses and all the census for
humans all the senses work together to
sense the world so i think for computers
um it is also our ultimate goal to let
different computer senses to work
together so i believe um the
cross-modality
including
vision
language
audio
and
other kinds of sensors
all these things should work together so
in in one short word um computer vision
is not alone and we we should um
think of
other senses and also this is um
i i think um consistent with uh dr
castle's view that we should uh think
computer vision in an environment
and as for the mission focused research
i think we already see many applications
of cv
in uh
in the manufacturing
industry or in some
retail industry for example the face
recognition
some scratchers
but
for me actually my focus is on
improving the
efficiency of information workers
so this might be uh related to uh
microsoft vision
because
the vision of microsoft is to
empower every person and every
organization on the planet to achieve
more
so
the mission of our group the intelligent
multimedia group is to build
seamless yet efficient multimedia
applications and services through
breakthroughs in fundamental theory and
innovations uh in algorithm and system
uh technology so i'm particularly
interested in um
in improving people's uh
efficiency especially information
workers efficiency through the advanced
uh computer vision technologies
so i i think i will stop here thank you
okay thank you
uh
yeah it's
i think yeah all the panelists share
very valuable points and all these
points are very important for us
yeah we also prepare several
questions for future discussion
okay
and yeah as you know deep learning has
been uh dominant to
incomplete region for almost 10 years
yeah maybe from
to
2012 yeah
and it seems get very successful in task
driven applications like
just cho mentioned very successful in
specific area like object categorization
autonomous driving face recognition
and etc
from these cases
the computer region seems to be a okay
application of deep learning or machine
learning now
yeah many researchers said okay it's
just a
application of machine learning
but as we are
most of us yeah yeah we start our
research from chemical region and at
that time computer region was a very
beautiful area
with physics
geometry
psychology
and other yeah very interesting topics
it seems all these modules
are behind data at this time
so i would like to
yeah
ask your question about
what's the unique aspects
of the computer region
in nowadays
okay yeah maybe
okay because this is a free discussion
okay
yeah just yeah give your opinions here
maybe yeah
ima
could you give us first your
ideas
what's the
yeah
yeah thanks for yeah this is a very good
question i believe actually probably
uh katsu in his presentation already uh
alluded to a good answer to this
question right
computer vision actually has very
originated from very diverse
the
domain knowledge physics
photo photogrammetry robotics and so on
right
from my personal point of view
so the learning based method data-driven
method has been very successful in terms
of very task-specific
setting where maybe the the model of the
problem physical model or geometric
model of the problem is not uh
is difficult to
to to derive
so
uh in the area that i showed in my
slides right um when you have the task
is very
demanding in terms of accuracy or in
terms of performance guarantee
then the domain knowledge such as
geometry becomes extremely important
um the purely data treatment method so
far has failed to be able to produce the
the kind of method the the the results
meet the kind of accuracy
such as in three division right you get
a very very good results but they are in
terms of accuracy and in terms of
robustness they are actually
quite
lower than what the geometric method can
give you but very complementary to what
the geometry
that's actually something that i think
is important on the other hand even from
a learning point of view even
let's say geometry can be
learned autonomously from the data
it may not be even necessary right every
single time you build a terms driving
system that system has to be trained to
learn all the fundamental geometry you
already know
right hence i think there's a great
success uh better success in the future
for for the deep learning
uh or for computer vision is precisely
to combine
um the the the power of data treatment
method
with the domain knowledge that the
computer vision has developed in the
past
on geometry
on the photogrammetry
and the physics and the kinematics of
the robots and so on right
let's hope that answer your question
yeah actually uh
you know
why computer vision unique because uh
dnn itself is invented from the human
visual system and
computer vision try to make a
alternative of human visual system so
they are perfect much
and
so basically a human visual system try
to make a
continuous lower level signal into
symbolic representation and the dnn is a
suitable
mechanism so
both computer vision and deep learning
area
corporate
cooperate each other and future you know
future is bright actually
that's my opinion
any opinions from
from
thank you um profgen this is a very good
question yeah
uh i i think uh if you um just use uh
deep learning as a tool then i think not
only the the vision
domain
actually deep learning
can be a tour actually to
many other domains and we cannot say
that all the domains are just
applications of
deep learning right because each domain
will have its own uniqueness and um
i think at early stage when deep
learning shows its power
people just apply deep planning to
various areas and
achieve many good results but eventually
i think the domain knowledge will play
an important role and just as pragma
just mentioned i think not only the
geometry but also the knowledge about
the appearance about um
the the
other appearance knowledge i think will
will play some role in uh for us to
better understand uh
from the
the vision system yeah
okay
thank you
yeah another question related to the
first one is yeah
in recent days okay they are beneficial
from their very repeat progress of
computational power and huge data
networking network becomes deeper and
deeper
yeah even maybe yeah thousands layers
is this the right way to solve computer
vision problems because some researchers
just believe that we have more data we
have more complex network
yeah all the problems seems to be solved
yeah if it's not
yeah
what's that right way yeah i i know yeah
you just mentioned some maybe some other
okay ways but okay
some people
just believe
this probably can even
to solve the general purpose capital
region
yeah i think it's quite uh close to the
last question
so you can yeah
well briefly give your ideas
yes um
okay
so um
yes you you all
um
are aware of um
recently big companies
uh
these are you know
investing a lot of huge resources to
build the
hyperscale ai systems right
like the uh you know um
gpt symbolism like that so
it requires huge amount of computational
power
and also a huge amount of data
so i think um
it's a good try
so because we haven't explored how far
we can reach
in terms of accuracy over or performance
of cv
algorithms
with the scalability of the network
capacity capacity
or the computational power and data as i
mentioned
so you you remember that
the resurgence of deep learning you know
um
around the 2010
is mainly due to the those factors right
computational power and large data
and new you know network capacity
something like that so
we'd like to see
how we can you know
go further
as though um how to make those big
networks
applicable or deployable to real
problems
so will be an interesting and
challenging problem still so
uh
in
that respect actually the academia
can
play a big role
compared with competing with the other
big companies
right
yes
any others
always just move to next one
okay let's move to the next one
okay so
yeah as
a part of ai your computer region
is closely integrated air interaction
with nlp
robotics and other related fields in
recent years
just like cardio mentioned
in his ports
meanwhile
multi-mode multimodal sensors
are also integrated in a vision system
is far beyond
our human region system because
it can integrate
other modalities a sense
and this does bring a lot of topics new
topics in this community
from your
experience
okay
what is the
the new challenges
i mean okay yeah
yeah because a lot of people work just
on yeah large models of explainabilities
and others what's the
most important topics in the
next
few years
yes this is quite close to kazu's
[Music]
issue is you available
how to fine-tune previously pre-trained
network
using a small data as human do
is a fast challenge
and second challenge
is science only progress only when
the contents are understood by us
so
self-explanability of the process is
again challenge of dna
and
third thing
as i mentioned in my previous talk you
know
does any
dl module want to run
or does any dl module have
self-consciousness probably no
and is it possible to make such a safe
area
or self-motivated
dna to improve or to adapt the
environment
that is a
big challenge
thank you
uh i i can add to that um um honestly i
think there are grander goals but i
think uh
if i wanted to challenge the visual uh
the learning community and the vision
community together
right we need to understand the
computational mechanisms
of how our visual inputs become our
memory
right and also um
compute it
against it
right um for example
we can train very large that network but
it's very hard to extend it
right and if there's additional class we
we all know our memory we can
incorporate we
enrich our memory by incorporating new
classes new objects new experiences
without interfering with our the things
we have learned in the past
and the the current practice of deep
network that has been a very big
challenge
um
for that how do we build establish
memory learn from our past visual
experiences and also be able to add upon
uh to that memory and then use for
future decision making or for our
perception as well
and i think that's more tangible task
that
really that pose a challenge for the
current practice of learning or computer
vision as well
yeah as chemo just mentioned yeah
yeah they're short lending uh their
short computer region so i think this is
also
yeah
related to the
yeah it's stability
kimono what's your opinion yes um
actually um current and ideal uh team
learning systems especially for the
company vision
so most of them are
passive
and steady right so usually we
human collect data set and then you know
train the system then the system usually
give the answers condition on
the provided data right
so
so generally general eligibility
is an issue so
we actually experienced you know many
times that the system performance on the
benchmarks is quite impressive
but while
when you applied when you try to apply
the system to real problem in the wild
then the gap
is quite large so there's a big you know
uh issue
here so i think that uh that
we have to
solve this
issue
to make the system deep learning system
to be
you know
active
and dynamic right so that the system
itself
can solve can improve
by itself and solve the problem
so this is quite related to the data
data issue
so
the unsupervised learning or unpaired
you know learning or self-supervised
learning
that could be the you know highly
important issue
so how to make how to construct the real
data and or how can how can you generate
realistic data set
how can you you know
come up with the future you know
situation
how to make the system progressive you
know something like that so those are
quite you know essential issue we have
to tackle in in the future
so do you have any idea yeah a very
short answer i think the biggest
challenge is
how to combine
knowledge
memory
and data
to make the computer system more
intelligent
okay
sex
yeah
as uh
can't you mention
that yeah region should be a part of a.i
and should be
yet
working in a system and a leading
environment so
yeah computer region at beginning
we tried to make a
general purpose system or general
purpose functions
but in the
last
two
20 or 10 years
yeah we get quite success
in
task specific
region system
so is that time for us to go back to
general purpose region
in research community
yeah because
yeah we don't we cannot i think we
cannot okay just use deep learning to
solve a problem by problem we need a
general purpose system
yeah if you if the answer is yes
then what's the possible roadmap
towards this goal
let's see
apparently you know this uh general uh
vision
argument is coming from a human visual
system
and certainly human visual system looks
like a general purpose vision machine
but i consider
it as a collection of special purpose
vision machine for example when you run
a new vision problem originally you
tried to solve it using all your
consciousness however for example
driving however when you get used to it
you can handle the same problem while
working on other problem so
apparently some of the modules become
special purpose vision machine
so along this line of sort we can
consider
what kind of task division will cover
the entire domain in artificial lifeform
environment with optimum divisions and
create
what is the optimum collection of
special purpose vision machine to
corresponding to those divisions so
that's kind of issue which we should try
to solve thank you
okay thank you very much for your okay
yeah very constructive points
and uh yeah
as we
have only very limited time so i have to
move to the last part yeah could you
give one will shock summarize on your
points
let's start from chong
okay uh so i want to say that computer
vision is not alone and data is not
everything we should
combine
computer vision we should consider
computer vision in a more comprehensive
sensing system and we also when we
tackle the computer vision problems
we should also consider
knowledge
in addition to data thank you
okay thank you
the end
yeah
i would like to share my screen actually
so basically we have to build a
friendly artificial iphone
and artificial life form should uh be
friends of human and human is a master
and the creator of the system
and actual lifetime should not aim
100 autonomous intelligence but should
aim at
90 percent of augmented intelligence
the reason is
i'm talking about a paradigm shift from
uh reductionism to horizon
but we have we shoot a 90 percent of
horizon
but in this cycle is just one cycle and
repeating this infinite loop of
reduction in horizon reduction in
horizon then we can create artificial
lifeform for understanding ourselves and
for understanding better human
environment
by combining
three
major areas computer vision robotics and
ai
hundred times thousand times
three thousand times thank you very much
you
yeah can you give your summarize
yes um i always has the view right the
nature
operates in the most simplistic and
fundamental way
rules and principles
right in terms of safe space
energy resource
right
and also i believe there is a chance now
we could through some of those
principles to understand
right the computational process or
mechanism that behind how
those mechanisms makes our visual human
visual systems so efficient so effective
and so diverse right i think we are sort
of at the diverge to be able to discover
some of the
computational principles now and thanks
for summer advance
in the deep learning or understanding of
machine learning or data analysis yeah
that's my view but hopefully in the next
10 years we'll be able to discover those
mechanisms a simple but universal and
effective rules
and important yeah it also works
yeah
came up it's your turn okay um
i believe that the uh division is not
over
but it just has started a new era okay
we have lots of new interesting and
challenging vision problems all of was
the solution of them will
play a vital role and eventually will
lead to
toward the human level ai
so let's enjoy
the journey together
thank
you okay thank you all the panelists
again for the as well thoughtful sharing
computer vision is a very important
topic and still has a lot of valuable
problems
to be solved in the future
and thanks for all the
panelists and
audience
thank you